[Music]
you dare enter this house
Thursday
you dare enter this house [__] uncle
Joey at Thursday August 24th swing and
dick and given our balloons you
understand me it's like a pedophile with
no probation it's a beautiful day to be
alive the clouds are out your nuts are
on fire nothing but the love from your
inner body is in your nuts I'm smoking
the little bit of this [__] hot
tamale we got some [__] no label
reefer from the one i jus and we still
got the container of [__] dead tea
understand me we ain't [__] around
today I don't know what you're doing
whatever you were thinking don't think
it because that's just [__] you're
just gonna get yourself to the same
predicament you've been all your [__]
life I love you [__] you make
my day
the church is up with [__] Bert
Kreischer knock yourself out it's
Thursday I'm in Ontario improv tonight
we're coming down with a bag of [__]
stars so you've never tripped before
tonight is your lucky [__]
night you understand me
let's bow some [__] reef it's
Thursday I want you guys to go out there
with the right attitude with the right
state of mind letting these
[__] know then you're in no
mood today are you taking hostages you
get your dick sucked and you squirt on
[__] eyeballs you understand me
you're taking it to the next level you
know why cuz you don't give a
Frenchman's [__]
enough is enough how many times you
gonna sit there take like a [__] dog
but anyway excuse me while I take a head
is one I do weed
that's some conquistadors [__] if you're
looking to flop and take over an island
today besides that it's all about you
[__] and how you're gonna make
it work today did you do your Tony to
push-ups did you write your goals
did you write what was in your heart so
when you want out there you know exactly
what the [__] you focused on what the
[__] the prize is today because if he
ain't out of the prize somebody else is
and by the time you get there it's gonna
be the same story yeah I lost my job to
go [__] yourself you gotta be on point
on a [__] daily understand me let
them think you're [__] I like the way
he's probably hi mi I'm watchin you like
a [__] hawk down sucker diet go for it
reach for it I'm Way ahead eat these
[__] don't know what you know
you know what you know that these
[__] don't know that heart
beats everything
you can come up with 20 [__] books
the size of my fat little [__] heart
will overcome anything I don't give a
[__] you have to shoot me in the head
with [__] 20 BB guns I hate stopping
you understand they tried to stop me 30
years ago what did get them well it get
up nothing nothing they've been trying
to stop uncle joy for [__] years but
you know what you know what this you
know what I got over anybody else I
don't give a [__] I keep showing up
persistence [__] them [__] them I do
show up damn get what before everyone
that's what you have to do in life ain't
nobody gonna give you dick understand me
the world don't know you dick if
anything you gotta get up there and
[__] steal it will give us a [__] you
understand me there's no conscious when
you're burning it out
what the man said I don't mind taking
bread from the mouths of decadence [__]
these [__] it's all about you
today
look at that like a [__] doctor
anyway I'm tell you improv tonight eight
o'clock please at the podcast vessel
he's gonna meet us done he's got the
small ship and the stars tomorrow night
two shows plus Eddie Bravo's showing up
to do a [__] guest set who's better
than that I think it's eight and ten
o'clock show but who gives a [__] just
get there early and then Saturday you're
probably gonna watch the [__] fight
my applaud you but the parties are uncle
Joey I don't dare you understand you
know why I'll tell you when you get that
[__] decide that it's time for
another boat right or wrong what what
right or wrong you didn't show up here
for me to [__] be you know be [__]
around I smoked another one and I smoked
this out and plan the day out so when
you go out there there's no
misunderstanding is this the most
important thing in life no
misunderstandings you lay your mark and
you [__] enforce it like Tony an 84
oh jesus [__] christ who sent the
boat uncle Joey did you're looking good
to let people be looking good you don't
dad you see I can see you [__]
looking tip-top Magoo ready to go out
there and put up with the challenges of
the day oh my god
I'm so stressed out don't suck my dick
with you nobody get stressed out that's
the state of mind for [__] weak
people savages like us we inflict
[__] stress you follow them that's
what's true that's what they're
stressing about us being in the room
because we're [__] savages when I
take it no for an answer
I don't know what the [__] you talking
about this but I'm doing tell that you
understand me I'm imposing my
[__] will today like let it's
good it 77 in [__] Oakland but that
your [__] back you down
I'm acid that's that
Joey love you you know without you
[__] I got nothing I'm not
gonna tell you that oh you know when I
wrote that joke he was a who gives a
[__] I said that [__] [__] the Actors
Studio
I'm telling you [__] how it is
what I you [__] I got nothing
let's keep up this [__] church family
and let's take all we know the church
family's about wonder dogs
we're underdogs and you know what we
enjoy being there so when we show up
we're like rocky Bob all we don't give a
[__] jack you better punch me and keep
[__] punching me because even if I
lose I'm gonna come back tomorrow huh
what if I bet you think I wrote this
this is what you're being your [__]
heart this is what you're being you
[__] balls and this is what you're
being your soul and if it's not you know
what go [__] shoot yourself this
eventually gonna sit there I should have
done a belly dancing course get the [__]
out here you should have done a lot of
things you understand me
I'm a felon I'm a loser
you know I got no self and nothing to
guess what I don't give a [__]
I go out and earn every [__] day with
three heads even if you cut one off am I
gonna have to push I'll grow another one
octopuses starfish you know I make
illogical system resort today but anyway
there's a [__] you guys know what I'm
saying and that's the most important
thing and the sad thing is you know what
I'm telling you is right you know enough
is enough you know you give a [__] you
don't give a [__] about nothing you may
believe you do that oh my god I supposed
to get that you don't believe it
you [__] you say that [__] so your
friends will tap you on the back oh
you're such a good guy I love Saturday
my life life too gonna [__] tolerate
that [__] speak from your heart
so who gives a [__] when you say the
truth you have less friends but the ones
that you have a [__] solid you
understand me and without that we got
together we had a little chitchat now
you know what your mission is for a
[__] Thursday seek and [__]
destroy they ain't stop and yeah I don't
give a [__]
and if Thursday fails listen no reason
to do a [__] swan dive off the bridge
you got Friday you come back tomorrow
stronger stronger stronger next week
will they doing the hair
I can't wait for Labor Day I'm gonna put
away my white shoes but really a mistake
a black shoe up your [__] ass
cuz I'm tap dancing and your [__]
soul you understand me we don't [__]
around it's the last border of the year
you gotta make something happen
so remember if not today mañana for the
Cubans in the house or a that didn't get
my might and I'm all wrong now or I am
bunny she happy that boy don't get me
started
anyway I love you mother Fox without
y'all have dick you guys the savages
don't let them tell you otherwise don't
let your therapist [__] get that
repition I'm sayin [__] em he sits there
listening with a pad getting two bills
an hour
[__] him to talk about you go out there
and pose your will that Mike Michael
Jackson said maybe Ford will stop til
you get enough right I see your
[__] tonight tomorrow night and
Saturday and Ontarian if not I'll see
you on the next one you know I love you
no matter one have a great day keep your
[__] our eyes off your phone and open
these guys are driving into people now
you know I'm Sam and we'll talk